so casa gonna be waiting he conscious in
doesn't check human reactions it's an
important part of the eSports experience
because it helps to both entertain and
inform the viewer because let's be
honest these games can be a little
overwhelming to outside now be it's
about to be caught oh there's the sleep
but sir he catches everyone this could
be a total
that's one trying to survive [__] gonna
go down I'm so Dale conceited but
eSports didn't always have life casting
the way it does now back in the day you
were lucky to have a cast at all and if
you did sometimes it sounded like this
it's raining
that's freak yes over that three tons of
damage the League of Legends that's hit
when he was a kid and evidently liked to
beatbox to It's Raining Men hallelujah
as cringy and strange as this is there's
actually a good reason behind it well
maybe not a good one but at least a
logical explanation for why he was
stalling hello hello hello hello oh damn
I just sang It's Raining Men rap style
oh right one minute mark let's unpause
this if you're not at the one-minute
mark well turn back this audio about a
min and a half listen to my rap again
then you'll be there see
casting isn't called that because it's
short for broadcasting like most people
think it's actually short for shoutcast
and even that is misleading
it's not called shoutcasting because of
how loud and excited some casters get
it's named after an ancient winamp
plug-in called shoutcast which let
people create their own internet radio
stations when antoinette it really whips
the llamas s yo u remember winamp right
with the llama
that's just more 1999 than orbits but
the llama it was named Mike I actually
think it died please stop it really
whips the llamas ass so back in the day
unless you lived in Korea where
Starcraft was on life TV play-by-play if
you wanted to hear your favorite cast or
commentate your favorite games you had
to download a replay of the game load up
there shoutcast station and wait for the
to to sync up which meant killing time
ha ha hello hello-o but casting did
exist before shoutcast at least to some
extent before online multiplayer most
competitive gaming happened in arcades
and there was usually someone calling
the action for the people in the back
that's actually how fighting game
commentator Yipes got his start
with the emergence of show cast though
there was now the opportunity to bring
the added dimension and excitement of
play-by-play
to online games to let's get this match
underway and those beginnings can be
seen in tribes
okay I'm gonna watch the red red for a
bit cuz he seems he's about the hub of
the 5150 defense if anything happens
I'll see it while watching him star
siege tribes was a 1998 fps that was
most famous for having incredible
movement options which made for a really
exciting high skill tap gaming
and here comes Snickers on his first
cameo right he actually meets a 51/50
long-range spammer at the middle of the
map that's Bryan French known in the
early days of tribes eSports as
wonderdog I I remember when I went with
the online name and I went how would
anyone pick something this bad
this is primetime I'm here with my
compatriot wonderdog I am wonderdog I'm
here with Mike no Patriot beats dick I
just got owned by myself
haha Brian is among the earliest casters
and got his start in a basement in
suburban Newmarket Ontario I was trying
out for the tribes World Championship
and in the middle of meeting all of my
teammates I met a guy who went by the
callsign of beat stick and we were all
saying where we were from and I said oh
I'm currently living in Newmarket and
you know I'm living in a basement
apartment with my life he said oh I live
in Newmarket - that's fantastic the same
holy ground responsible for producing
NHL superstar caller Rick David McDavid
trying to split the defense late 90s
rock band serial Joe
and the unwitting father of smokin Jim
Carrey somebody is hot man
anyway it's thanks to guys like Brian
that modern eSports broadcasts look the
way they do now for me there are four
pieces that you needed to have in order
to do a really good play by play and
coverage radio style for a broadcast he
needed to have a person who could call
the action so that the minds eye could
see what you see the Big Apple and
snacks is hungry he's got one kill
already on the USP low HP as well on
Guardian and flame he's trying to beat
them out and then secondly you need it
to have that old veteran player who
carried that level of respect we needed
to have the tech support guy gerrae I
need you to plug those servers in now
captain and we needed to have a
recognized name already in the field
being able to do promotion and being
able to do additional coverage but TSN
didn't see that the future of casting
would be built on the personalities and
in French's opinion that was a mistake
we had modeled ourselves after ESPN I
mean who wasn't who who who doesn't
remember the catchphrase from the 2000s
we want to be the ESPN of eSports
broadcasting everyone said that one of
the things he SBN did and I don't think
it was correct just personally I don't
think it was correct was that they
promoted the network more than they
promoted their talent
repeat after me and the talent always
wins TSN and other radio style
broadcasts faded away as eSports moved
to TV in the mid 2000s and then
justin.tv and twitch TV later on
the rise of these streaming services was
crucial to launching the era of
personality focused broadcasts and as a
result set casting duo's began to
develop from taste dosis to ultra chen
to anders and similar characters got
charged him down is it miss quite a few
pistol shots kenny yes he wanna kill
[Music]
around
oh my lord that should not happen that
is why possibly one of the most
depressing things I've seen so far but
these sports casting isn't the only
thing that's come a long way the
broadcast has - ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to the AMIA Convention
Center at Yan shipping Sweden just look
at the first league of Legends World
Championship we are here for the
Dreamhack summer 2011 championship game
the finals about to go on her way
$100,000 tournament held by League of
Legends day at Riot Games
the event was held at dreamhack 2011 in
sweden but long time league fans like to
say it was held in freaks basement
because of just how cheap it all team
solomid in third place is going to be
presented there check by matt Marku
let's bring them out right now
[Applause]
since then purse strings have been
loosened and as a result eSports
broadcasts have improved by leaps and
bounds
we've gone from freaks basement to
augmented reality dragons in the bird's
nest
[Music]
from crowded arcades to Mandalay Bay
from 360p to 1080p and it's not just the
biggest events even the week to weekly
broadcasts have gotten better sure we
still get the occasional fuck-ups like
technical delays Diego's the portal now
he texts up when we can have ourselves a
pause the game actually crashes over or
not easy
spectator problems seemed possible to
take full control of the games and audio
issues but thankfully these random
instances of jank production have become
the exception rather than the rule let's
take a moment to unveil the newest
banner to the battle arena and recognize
how spring split champions
ladies and gentlemen tee over the course
of the last seven years broadcast and
the casters themselves have become a
fundamental pillar of eSports
they are the spectators window into a
scene and the type of impression they
make can be crucial to making new fans
[Applause]
and do the eSports his younger audience
and the less restrictive informal nature
of the streams themselves casters are
able to have a lot more fun with the
broadcast okay so let's get a countdown
let's go for the big countdown let's go
from 10 then that man is going in this
high bath 10
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's a part of the reason why so
many people want to become casters the
fact of the matter is that with enough
work anyone can get into casting hi I'm
Jake
also known as sir action slacks
regrettably I should have been colonel
quit that was number two so ah everyone
starts out as an amateur and gets
noticed through skill and that makes
those personalities even more accessible
well he doesn't have the range does not
the length that's why his wife meets up
with a guy behind the shed just look at
dota caster OD pixel who started out
literally casting in his bedroom and
this year finally made his dream of
casting TI grand finals come true
[Applause]
your Grand Champions
it's G because of all that testers have
taken as important to place in the
broadcast as players I'm going to my
brain says SK TV but I got that Chinese
pride I'm friends with table a Royals
gonna win I'm friends with table a
that's you're voting it's alright you
may not ride the Korean hype train but
I'll just have you ride the bench next
season o people don't just have
favourite casters to get invested in
those casters get excited when they're
invited to events or disappointed when
they won't be able to hear them at a
tournament talent has become the message
in a way that those early productions
like TSN didn't understand people don't
just remember the hype plays they
remember how's it casters called books a
couple smokes in the same place
this is the SPO this is a major Baker
maybe a trouble your death Bart tries to
clean it up for real oh look at the
class look at the boat thank you
why was that
good they're all together PPT he comes
the ice blocks ready for the you know if
we didn't have this show I think we'd
make a pretty hype casting duo this is
it the grand final of the 2018 primal
rage office championships
brought to you by win amp 2019 parently
that's it all comes down to Dan jazz
hands rosin and calling the moustache
McNeil who's gonna take it Oh
call it just has no answer for the Agra
Raptors range and Dan closes up a series
with a furious nine to combo
wow what a grand final would you take
away for that miles I guess you can say
the Dan everyone how you spank the
monkey is that really all you're gonna
add to this what else did you expect
Colin just has no answer for the Agra
Raptors range
oh wow